let's bring you some developing news
coming out five Bulgarian Nationals
suspected of spying for Russia to be
charged with conspiracy to conduct
Espionage now they'll appear in the UK
court next week they're accused of
conspiring to gather information which
would be useful to an enemy
it's more of this let's talk now to
Jonah Harley joins us live from London
so what more details are coming to light
about this alleged spy ring
well these so-called hostile State
threats are said to account for an
increasing proportion of the work load
of the UK Security Services the more so
those emanating from Russia since the
attempted assassination of Sergey
scripal back in 2018 and this is one of
those so-called hostile State threats as
you said there five people Three Men and
two women all Bulgarian Nationals have
been charged now by The Chronic Crown
prosecution Service uh here charged with
conspiracy to conduct Espionage they
will come up in court to answer those
charges on Tuesday next week more widely
the charges involve the five operating
uh in an operational Spy cell uh
conspiring to gather information useful
to an enemy between August 2020 and
February 2023 that following an
extensive investigation by the
Metropolitan Police essentially living
in plain sight these five here in the
United Kingdom officers searching
properties belonging to at least three
of them found alleged fake passports and
official ID documents for a whole host
of countries not just the UK but across
Europe including Bulgaria France Italy
Spain Croatia and the Czech Republic as
well they're believed three of the five
at least have lived here for several
years two of them indeed living as a
couple in a quiet cul-de-sac in a place
called Harrow not far from London they
were known as Max and Kate locally not
their real names of course they were
said to have kept a low profile and
indeed lived for a number of years next
door to a policeman
all right we'll leave you there thanks
so much Jonah Hull